it's great to be joined today by dr.
Adam ghazali who is professor in
Neurology physiology and psychiatry at
the University of California San
Francisco founder and executive director
of neuro scape a translational
neuroscience Center engaged in
technology creation and scientific
research and also author of the
distracted mind so Adam we're going to
touch on a couple different things here
but I guess to begin with when we talk
now
the term technology addiction has become
very common sort of in the context of
smartphones and the internet from a
medical perspective what do we mean when
we say an addiction to technology well
you know it's complicated because the
clinical definition of addiction which
usually applies to things like drug
addiction but has stretched over into
behavioral addictions like gambling
usually what we mean is a almost
obsessive compulsion to engage in
something that has functional negative
consequences on your life and then there
are other aspects that are debated
whether you've obituaries rahl but in
general it's excessive engagement with
negative consequences is it more
difficult for someone who maybe does not
regularly disconnect from their
smartphone on the early internet to
realize that they may have an addiction
because they're not even sort of
presented with the opportunity to
experience withdrawal yeah you know I
think that we see it in all types of
engagement not just technology in terms
of Internet but you know video games and
just even you know cell phone use in
general and texting you know if you
never are confronted with how something
is impacting your life it is possible
that they could go you know without your
awareness how prevalent do you believe
that technology addiction is right now
and I don't know how we can even maybe
we say in the United States or in OECD
countries I mean I don't know what data
we might have but
can we assess the prevalence of this
issue I'm not too sure the data on that
and it's really hard to find that data
because the definitions are so variable
I think what's more important is to just
look at the negative effects of it and
see how common they are without the
labels even even the terms that we use
to label clinical prediction of
conditions like ADHD and autism are
often coming under stone challenge in
that the labeling process itself is is
imprecise let's now talk about sort of
how this relates to the way human brains
are sort of wired or inherently based on
our history in in Prior times before we
had industrialization modern technology
sort of modern Western culture talked a
little bit about the concept of
multitasking and the ways in which the
brain sort of reacts to moving from one
activity to another and maybe even how
that sort of served us in earlier times
in human history yes so the human brain
is it's amazing obviously I don't have
to convince anyone of that I would say
the most remarkable aspect of the human
brain is our goal-setting abilities
these very long time delayed complex
interweaving goals and whatever goals as
well with other people's goals but we
have these fundamental limitations and
how we enact those goals we call those
the abilities that allow us to do that
cognitive control our attention
abilities where we direct our limited
resources where and when we want them
holding that information in mind for
short periods of time something we call
working memory and then hope by tasking
and we are capable of doing this in
terms of our behavior but what we see
when we look at someone's brain with
functional neuroimaging as they attempt
to engage in or the one intentionally
demanding a task is that the brain
network that is activated to do one task
disengages at a new net
work is engaged we have a secondary task
what we don't see is parallel processing
of two tasks that you're engaged in it
both demand attention and so this is
just a fundamental limitation of all
brands and we see it across the app you
know all other animals and humans like
so we're the distracted mind comes in is
a is the conflict between our goals what
we want to do what were actually capable
of doing and although other animals have
these same limitations on multitasking
they don't really attempt to engage in
the environment in that way so they
don't have that same problem so it
sounds sort of like this is both a
nature and nurture thing in the sense
that when one might think that they're
multitasking really what they're doing
is switching sometimes rapidly from
focusing for a short period of time on
one task to focusing on another one
there must be some time costs in terms
of that switching that takes place but
is there also somewhat of a is this a
muscle of sorts in other words can the
sort of brain activity that is
encouraged by modern technology
smartphones etc can it put our brains
sort of out of practice of the habit of
deeper and longer focus on one task sure
so it was a lot in the back in a little
bit I mean nature nurture of course most
everything is the nation of our genetics
and environmental influences and this is
a very very nice example of that the
cost that you talk about is what we pay
a lot attention to as scientists and
it's people that are interested in
interference effects whether it be some
distraction or multi tasking or a phone
ringing around really exactly this fits
checked in mind for you in real world
what we see you know is a cost in both
response time as you described but also
in accuracy just the fidelity of
information that you're holding in mind
is degraded when interrupted as I just
was by another task and interfering
stimulus the question of plasticity can
we build up this ability so let's listen
in both directions it doesn't really
have a morality it takes you wherever
the influence is it modifies and
responds so if you spend your time
constantly switching whether you're
having a conversation you jump on
Twitter you move to your email you're
listening to music if you engage in that
way then it's very reasonable that other
skills that you're not practicing such
as sustained focus attention will become
weaker and each of you retrained what
are some good just basic practices for
the average person who maybe has a job
that depends pretty significantly on
being on technology devices internet
email etc and who wants to sort of enact
some protections to what can be this
natural slide to this regular switching
between tasks and scrolling on social
media feeds not ideas that will
basically take them out of the world
that they're in by virtue of being in
modern Western society but just sort of
day to day things everybody could do
yeah it's a great question I always like
to frame is that I love technology a lot
a lot I use the same tools that most
everyone has maybe even more and I don't
think this is a black or white issue I
don't think technology is good or bad
it's just that based on a better
understanding of where the weaknesses
and how our brain processes information
you can make an informed decision about
how you engage in technology which is
really the core of your question so I
would say if you recognize the
limitations and feel them and
acknowledge them and and how broad they
are how they impact not just your work
or your schoolwork but your social
interactions how they might impact your
safety if you're texting and driving
once you acknowledge them then you get
to make decisions and one of the
decisions that I make is that when I'm
engaged in something to really demand a
high level of quality especially if it's
time pressure associated with it I shut
off my other technological streams you
know I quit my email I shut my other
browsers if I'm working on one I close
my door I turn my plant
my phone to airplane mode as I should've
today and I really work by focusing on
that one thing I can tell you from my
own personal experience it's not easy to
do if you set in an hour
just some tasks you may not get through
it especially if you're not use to it so
in that case I would say that it's most
important to fit breaks they might only
be five minutes long and it's important
that those breaks are not going on
social media or even back into your
email because those to be clearly sort
of iterative sinkholes that just take
you further and further away from
getting back to your goal so the three
things that I do are either walk in
nature or looking looking at nature it
should to have a strong restorative
effect like physical exercise it could
be a walk again or push-ups or just
getting moving and then meditative
online illness like practices where you
quiet your mind focus on your breath and
then return to what you're engaged in
and as the days go on of taking these
periods of pilot you've got singular
focus you can go longer and longer
without a break until you can find that
it's actually pretty fun to act work on
one thing at a time we've been speaking
about the book the distracted mind the
book's author has been speaking with me
dr. Adam ghazali professor in neurology
physiology and psychiatry at UCSF thanks
so much for talking to us about this
because hi pleasure thank you